The CW certainly knows as brands and the
company is shooting right down the
middle with 2018 s breakout its
all-american the series is a
dramatization of the real-life story of
Spencer Paysinger a star football player
from South Los Angeles who Big C odds to
make it all the way to the NFL where he
played linebacker for the New York
Giants
Spencer James as a lead character of the
show based loosely on pasanga his
fish-out-of-water story has captivated
audiences from the get-go earning
all-american and early renewal for not
just a second season but also a third
the story of an outsider person s just
trying to find they are in this world if
the fresh-faced young actor portraying
the charismatic safety looks familiar to
you there's probably a reason why
spencer james has played by Daniel Ezra
an accomplished young actor and veteran
of both the stage and TV let's break
down the roles that led him here and
highlight the projects you might have
seen him in before being an English
actor born in Birmingham in the West
Midlands Daniel Ezra naturally kicked
off his professional career in British
productions he began acting in 2014
making a small screen debut in the
television movie murdered by my
boyfriend
Ezra then landed a one-off role on the
BBC drama series the village and the
critically acclaimed movie blood cells
in 2014 in 2016 Ezra scored the role of
Dan Johnson on undercover a six-part BBC
drama that centers on a human rights
barrister fighting to free an American
inmate from death row fans may also
recognize Azra as Daniel Reed from
season two of anthology series the
missing or as DC Ashton from the police
procedural prime suspect 1973 that
series rolled out in 2017 but for this
young actor 2018 was the year that
changed everything before he landed the
leading role an all-american Ezra had
another memorable TV turn as the fan Uwe
Wilson on the British series a discovery
of witches that show is an adaptation of
the popular or souls trilogy of fantasy
novels by Deborah Harkness the story of
the series centers on Diana Bishop a
historian and witch who discovers an
ancient grimoire in Oxford's body and
library this revelation proves
unfortunate as it draws Diana deeper
into a world of magic and evil creatures
that she would prefer to leave well
enough alone
Ezra's character Nathaniel Wilson crops
up in the very first episode as a demon
computer wiz with a
for a daughter although Ezra wasn't
listed as a principal cast member his
character occurred throughout the first
season and had a memorable impact on the
plot it was likely this appearance more
than anything else that guts Ezra
noticed by casting directors and paved
the way for his leading role an
all-american while the football drama is
undoubtedly the 27 year old actors
biggest break to date it's fair to say
his career got a major boost from his
role on a discovery of witches witches
was renewed for two more seasons back in
2018 but there's been no announcement
regarding whether as Rob or return we
assume the CW is keeping him pretty busy
back in 2017 Ezra put his classical
training to use playing Sebastian in the
national theaters live performance of
Shakespeare's Twelfth Night
the gender-bending comedy is one of the
bars most famous works and Sebastian was
a solid role for such a new talent the
story of Twelfth Night concerns
intersecting cases of mistaken identity
in the play Sebastian is a twin brother
to viola he's lost at sea in the first
scene and presumed dead by his sister
there was later revealed that he
survived the shipwreck by clinging to
the mast of his broken vessel he's
rescued by the sailor Antonio who
ultimately falls in love with him while
Asura's character is off stage for much
of the plays action he does return to
take part in the comedies amusing
conclusion Twelfth Night gave us with a
chance to cut his teeth performing low
theater for a TV audience an opportunity
that any young actor would certainly
relish so next time you see him chasing
a reciever a Spencer James remember that
the dude can also do Shakespeare I'm
just playing check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]